[Musique]
dubaï même chose bizarre
l'expérience un peu étonnante quand on
sait pas ce qui va arriver c'est bien et
bah là vous allez être servi et bien des
acteurs il y en a une histoire
il y en a une à peut-être c'est vous qui
allez nous raconter encore mais pour ça
il testing espace xla regardez bien les
stoehr est là qui brûle en enfer
jésus c'est vraiment inquiétant la même
voix éraillée que ce pauvre martin
personnellement j'ai toujours éprouvé
s'est amusé est chéri est ce que tu
trouves vraiment que ce sont des
amuseurs on ne comprenait pas ce que je
supporte et au delà des forces humaines
écoute le les mêmes expressions que mon
mari de son vivant qu'est ce que c'est
c'est pour vous de la part de votre
premier mari qui
alors il ya quelqu'un en a assez vu
9000 personnes qui a l'air très fatigué
enfin même presque mouvante
non non enfin je vais pas l'air très
très fatiguée très mauvais état quoi il
ya là une femme une fille qui à côté qui
sur ça on a l'impression ça lui fait des
souvenirs
qu'est-ce qu'il fait des souvenirs ce
que dit l'autre s'était dit l'homme quel
genre de soudières l200 premier mari qui
est mort il est mort d'accord ça qu'il
est mort elle le dit lundi qu'il
attendait voilà vous mettez en doute là
elle dit il est rageant c'est plus en
disant qu'il est mort dix ans que je
prends une décision
il m'a appelé pour lui tant pis pour lui
ensuite dont elle parle de ça que ça lui
rappelait son nid en vitesse l'autre le
bonhomme
quel bonhomme celui qui à côté du
téléphone oui il est jeune dieu plutôt
zone trentaine d'années maximum en
france et que ce téléphone sonne alors
ce monsieur là il décroche on il dit à
loos et de la part de qui on est
il fait ça et si c'est ton premier mari
et la fille dit qu'ils coin et sa fille
nicole il s'agit de quoi comment où et
comment genre de film fantastique du
fantasme non pas fantastique
bizarre s'il est mort parce que figé
malentendu ça change tout
passe des choses étranges été d'appeler
théoriquement donc le premier mari est
mort et puis il me voilà au téléphone et
puis je sais pas il doit y avoir un truc
parce qu'il parle de jésus celui qui m'a
changé pourquoi qui parle de jésus le
malade à celui qui a l'air malade il
s'en est tout ça n'était qu'une dans le
film sur un film il peut y avoir un truc
comme télépathie parce qu'il dit j'ai
des pouvoirs surréaliste j'ai des
pouvoirs à we decided j'ai des pouvoirs
machin et pour mes choix des pouvoirs
plus plus fort que les humains comme ça
alors ce qui fait qu'il peut avoir qui
peut télépathique et ils puissent télé
pâtir à adé à des âmes quoi laisser à
mes et là il y téléphone t il à l'est
par les six premiers mois s'est un peu
embrouillé et vous ça vous intéresserait
le revoir alors ça vous souhaitez second
rideau vert c'est vraiment écoeurant les
voisins n'arrête pas depuis ce matin
aujourd'hui
de quoi trouver comme ceux qui tirent tu
vas t'en colle et d'énergie
ils ne comprennent pas voici voilà la
pente sont virés de la semaine tiens les
gouttes
c'est le maire qui l'ont bien en
arrivant qu'est-ce que j'ai inventé moi
de la part de et qu'est-ce que j'ai
inventé moi
bon ça comment j'ai pu imaginer qu'ils
disaient qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans
ma tête
ayé quelque chose qui va pas parce que
elle n'a pas du tout parlé de mort et
aucun rapport avec l'excusé de semaine
non c'est pas possible ça peut pas
excellent parce que puisqu'il a parlé de
jésus il a dit quelque chose comme ça
maintenant au dessus il est peut-être
dit mais elle a bien dit elle à paris
ces personnages que tout a bird
oui mais ça me dit même pas ce que c'est
impossible avec des bougies la saison
qui avait tout pareil et pourtant c'est
pas ça ça me dit même presque il me
semble avoir entendu deux des trucs de
mort et tout du coup maintenant qu'est
ce qu'il raconte
aulas il parlait qu'ils n'arrêteront pas
au dessus j'ai les miens quittera pour
tous va attendre ma chance ça aucun
rapport quoi parle des jo qui quoi qui
parle de l'histoire avec des gens de
l'eau dessus mais c'est pas pareil moi
j'imagine ya un truc fantastique enfin
un truc
et là c'est plus non pas du tout c'est
quoi une normale
un feuilleton en fait ça peut être un
peu ton quand même noter que n'importe
quoi ou les le revoir ouais
c'est thomas coville
je suis vraiment amoureux qui il veut
dire les espions arrêtés ce matin
officiellement on n'a pas pu prouver
qu'ils ont voulu vous brisez ai vraiment
assez comparable
c'est quand ils parlent tous et à l'âme
forum l on tient bon à l'époque des
vaches on a des amis en france
qu'est ce que c'est c'est pour vous de
la part de votre premier ministre
alors oui alors là j'ai compris en fait
c'est exactement la même scène mais en
fait en amis des doublages vraiment on a
pris d'autres voix il enfin les mêmes
voies puis ils ont un truc c'est pour ça
je me suis fait avoir je ris me disent
ah si ce n'était pas possible
déjà quand tu parlé en espagnol c'est
bien je veux pas tu m'as bien on va la
première fois que je serai une brouille
voir sinon je vais vous faire voir
encore une autre fois mais d'abord parce
que celle que je vous fais avoir
maintenant deux versions c'est la vraie
ou la belle raconte quoi c'est vous qui
allez me le dire avant d'après vous dans
ce genre de de décor avec ses
personnages qui sont là
quel est le véritable centre alors
amélie salaire d'un d'un anniversaire
qu'il ya des bougies alors dieu quelle
qu'elle soit
moi j'imagine mais j'imagine mal le mari
oui qui fait avec l anniversaire son
père il fait tout d'un coup un coup de
téléphone claqué décroche à l'eau est
doux et c'est son ex mari alors là c'est
la panique c'est pourquoi ils dominaient
alors la effet une tête comme ça parce
que j'ai fait quelque chose que les
fonds marins eh ben ça va se terminer
avoir un plan e 2 qui se retrouvent sur
les champs-elysées ils égaient le
l'époux enfin non le la dame là la fille
là et puis bon là mans nice à l'elysée
s'en vont il se retrouva avec le ca qui
pue pas là puisque le sac où ils sont
simples je veux bien ça qui balance son
sac elle recule à 28 cents voilà lectra
vers des tribus
oui voilà non il passe y à l'arc de
triomphe la paix passe à travers claque
savez comme suit pas une porte pas une
ode lui ça change
eh bien on va voir si les scénaristes du
véritable film on pensait comme
[Musique]